in order to survive the movie business
long-term how essential is it for an
actress to also write direct and produce
like you're doing keep that career going
in my opinion incredibly essential
acting is a tough gig man it's hard I
have so much respect for my friends that
are actors and they have representatives
and they go out on those auditions but
you're waiting for somebody to pick you
that's tough
it's just tough you know you're waiting
for somebody to pick you so that they
can tell their vision and I know people
that make a lot of money and they're
doing something you know on television
or in film they make a ton of money but
they're bored really because they're
just not enjoying the stories that are
out there I've seen character seven
eight nine ten years you know you're
making a ton of money but you're not
really you don't feel creative anymore
you know and it's like
and then the problem with that
especially if it's in television is you
do TV and you do a show and it lasts ten
years and then it's over and then you go
off and you're like all right I'm free I
want to do this and they go no but
you're the guy from that show so we
don't want the guy from that show in our
film it's like now you're that guy you
know how long do you have to be that guy
before people realize you're not that
guy that's a made-up guy and you can do
other things it's tough it's very very
tough what I learned or discovered in
writing was that I could create my own
vision and I could take full
responsibility for it and I could create
whatever I wanted to create now that
comes with disadvantages
you know money is not gonna come first
when you do it that way you're gonna be
up against different obstacles but
they're all obstacles like it's either
I'm either trying to find a way
make it work for a little bit of money
or I'm sitting around staring at a phone
that's not ringing they're both hard you
know but the end game is what I think
you always have to be mindful of like
what do you want and I think if you
really want to show your artistic nature
and you really want to showcase yourself
in the best light what you do well I
think you know get out there and make
your own stuff and if you don't have
that if you don't feel like you have
that then like you know team up with
people that do and and and make a team
and you know the three four or five of
you together create something that's
uniquely your own the tribe finite tribe
yeah find your folks go find your folks
it's hard you know there's people out
there that have been represented for
years and they haven't worked there's
people out there that are brilliant and
they don't have representation it's very
difficult but anybody can post stuff on
YouTube anybody can go on Twitter and
start building an audience for
themselves and now apparently they're
looking for that I just read a thing the
other day casting directors they care
more about your Twitter following than
they do about your talent you know if
you're an actor that's like getting
punched in the balls you know I mean
that's terrible but it's a reality of
how it works
so how do you combat how do you do that
how do you combat that like how do you
become the guy that's got enough Twitter
followers if you're sitting around
waiting for your phone to ring and
you're waiting for somebody to pick you
you got to start doing something we've
got to get up and do it it's different
it's a different world you used to be
able to like pitch and weight you could
go in and be like this is great oh yeah
it sounds awesome
here's a check let's see how it turns
out those days are gone
stays gone you can buy a camera that can
create visuals that can be put on a
screen theatrically cars to grand people
are out there I'm shooting
man it's about shooting show now money
doesn't come first now now you got to
show what you can do you got to go out
there you got to shoot something and
make it great for nothing and then say
here's what I did so that you're not
saying we have a lot of interest whoa
you gotta show people like what do you
do
what's your lay script late a script
check out my flick look at the movie oh
yeah what do you think I could do if I
had 10 grand more 50 grand more hundred
grand more shooting show what have you
learned is the biggest some of the
biggest budget wasters because you you
know you're talking about some of the
budgets you're working with and uh where
have you kind of reined back you know my
budgets are so tiny
not a whole lot to waste on mine but I
think I think the best thing the best
thing the bet the hardest thing is time
managing the time you know because when
you're doing something for so little
everybody's got to love it
it's got to be about passion but you
also can't sit around wasting your time
you can't waste their time people are
coming to you and they're bringing you
great stuff so you can make this movie
you owe it to them to know what the hell
you're doing at least know what the hell
you want can't sit around me like I
don't know I don't prepare know what you
want you know Woody Allen says if you're
the writer of the story you already know
what you want the audience to see so as
a director I try to figure that out know
what it is when people come in we hit
the ground running I'm not here to waste
your time I'm here to facilitate you
having fun and having your passion get
displayed so let's get to it let's make
it happen do it and then you can go home
and pet your cat do whatever you do come
back do it again later oh yeah timing
really timing
giving people the time to do what they
do best but not wasting time trying to
figure out how it's going to do do all
that work at the time
you